Hello!
Whoops!
Second time, third time's the charm!
That's right!
Refresh the leaderboard!
Refresh it!
Plus one!
Plus one stream!
I demand a rank reset right now!
Plus one, another stream!
I'm glad I'm here!
climbing up the rankings plus one I don't get they don't use
they don't goodbye
all right all right well it doesn't count I could I could
have just looped that several more times I literally just
got back from doing some errands today I touch grass guys
touch grass say okay wait let me push up dad a little higher
give me a sec my I just want Dad to be up a little bit
higher.
All right.
Today, we're going to do a rewrite.
Rewrite time for choicer voicer.
For those who don't know, it is a, I mean, I feel like it's
a Twitch game anyway.
So I feel like a lot of you guys might know this game.
Give me a second.
I need to fix this real quick.
A lot of you guys already know what this game is because it
is a game that's has sort of blown up a little bit on
Twitch.
So I flew too close to the sun.
The last time I tried to play this on, I'm sorry, your
immersion a little bit, a little bit again, put this down.
So last time I played this game on YouTube, I got a little,
I got nuked a little bit.
I saw Nimi playing it today a little earlier.
I was like, you're so brave.
You're so brave, especially with what happened to me.
Oh, wait, both Twitch chats are on.
Give me a sec.
Let me fix that.
just realized that I have both twitch chat on um I uh she's
so brave she saw me fly close to the sun and died in the
ocean and then she's like I bet I can do that too but but
this time but I'll do it different it creates too so brave
so brave of her uh yeah to be fair she didn't do any of the
Disney stuff that's true that's true from me she learned
from my mistakes so yeah it's basically we dubbed some we
dubbed some clips and I'm gonna mute myself while I'm
dubbing so it'll be a little surprise for both of us when we
listen to it for the first time together so we'll both be
surprised of how that's gonna sound like all right let's see
it let me check the how what is the audio for this game i
saved it so give me a sec all right it is at 3.9 decibels
all right so we're doing again it's sequel time rewind time
part two choicer voicer everything's gonna go down today but
i did some errands today I finally went to this little,
okay, I finally, it was a little bit like fear in me because
I went to this coffee shop.
So, Shacky, thank you for the gift.
It's here.
One sub.
Thank you.
And I've always patched through this coffee shop all the
time when I was like, whenever I like, I do like errands or
walking, like going someplace that's close to my place.
And there was this coffee shop.
And it's really, it's a really cute coffee shop where they
have like these, I don't want to say exactly what kind of
desserts they are because they'll narrow you.
narrow it down.
Like I don't want to like talks where I am and or anything.
Um, but they have like these like, what's the word?
Like very unique types of desserts, you know, like, you
know, have some coffee shops when they do desserts.
It's not like just a regular, just cakes and like just a
normal type, like chocolate cake and stuff like that.
They have like unique desserts in a way where it's like,
what's the word?
What's the word?
Uh, for like cute, like cute designs or cute you know like
those okay this is not the dessert i was eating but you know
like and i know it just got really popular in la but uh
there was these there is these like dessert chains that
started making like um tarts and stuff tarts and moose that
are like fruit shaped like those types of desserts uh but it
wasn't i didn't eat that kind but you know like the more
more innovative artisan yeah artisan desserts um i've always
wanted to try one the those types of desserts where it's
like it's shaped like a mango um but it's like a dessert
like a pastry i've always wanted to try one but i've never
tried one yet i try i actually they started like you can
actually buy them now at supermarkets uh obviously it's not
the same it's not like a pastry sort of like an ice cream um
but then like i bought it and i forgot about it and now and
it expired and i was like no when will i ever go okay wait i
need to know if the supermarket is local to my area like
um is it outside of okay i need to know if it's local um in
my area okay it is okay it's not okay that's good no i don't
want to go back to tnt like and it's so far it's sorry i
have to stop myself to know if it's local here i i was just
like travel I don't have a car I want to go to TNT again to
buy it oh it's so far from where I live and if you go to TNT
you have to buy a lot of stuff I don't want to carry all of
that again back home Wow so so that's I was like no it's so
fired so I haven't been back to TNT in a while because like
I don't want to go back like I mean I do want to I okay so
I'm like in the more I'm in the moral dilemma right now I do
want to go back but I know it's gonna be so painful going
back because I have to carry so much stuff coming back it's
just me by myself but then all the stuff I want to buy so
much stuff when I'm there like the big for those who don't
know what tnt is it's like um canada's biggest um um asian
supermarket like they have everything you can get anything
like asia related like like pastries food noodles um like
anything asian related you go there because it's like the
it's like the asian supermarket and it's huge.
Like even live fish, you can get live like fish or lobsters,
crab, everything.
They kill them live for you.
Like, you know, it's like those types of Asian supermarkets
where you point at a fish and they'll kill it in front of
you.
Like that type of supermarkets, you know?
So it's like the, it's like, yeah, and it's like the biggest
Asian supermarket chain in Canada um anyway so like I I love
going to TNT by very I by very rarely go to TNT just because
I don't have a car and also I'm just one person and I my
arms are so tired I have noodle arms and I don't want to
because it's like I it's far too so it's like why do I have
to go so I have to
and I'm not gonna buy one thing.
If I'm going so far, I'm not gonna, I could order it.
Wait, they do, okay, the thing is, but then you'll be like,
Yoki, why don't you just do delivery?
They do online deliveries.
The thing is, the last time I did online delivery, I bought
too much.
Where I just didn't have space anymore.
I bought so much, this is what happened last time too.
I bought so much that half the items expired before I could
eat any of it.
So that's why I don't do online orders from TNT because I
know it's going to happen again.
I would see, I think I spent so much money because I was
like, oh my God, they have online orders.
And I'd be like, I'll take this, I'll take that.
Whoops, I was like, shop can carry.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
And that's why my mango fruit ice cream expired, guys.
That's how it expired.
I can't, don't buy so much.
That's like telling me to fucking not breathe.
left how how dare you you want me to just die like in game
in game in my crap in my crap in my crap no twitch is a
little bit more um scary about that yeah just say you hate
me already exactly
yeah so so so i can't order online because I don't trust
myself.
I don't trust myself.
Because last time I did half the stuff I ordered expired
because I just, I can't help myself.
And I can't, I don't know.
I don't know if I have it.
I just don't know if I bought too much.
It's like, this is what happens when I'm becoming an adult
with like disposable income.
I don't know.
I don't know my limits.
The only way I know my limits is when I'm like buying stuff
in real life.
Like, you know, not on ordering online because then it'll be
like how much can I carry home and usually the amount of
stuff I can carry home is not that much like I at least I'll
be able to at least I'll be able to consume all this stuff
Before it expires, but now but when you order online It's
like it's like the limiters are off, you know, you're like
oh my god I I can order so many things.
Oh my it's like when you're What's like the PC lingo when
you I'm like overclocking it.
I'm gonna over overclock my shopping cart.
I mean...
Sir Bunn, thank you for the 50 bitties.
Thank you, thank you.
Hazard, thank you for the 100 bitties.
Your stream, your steamed ham Simpson dub was so good.
Disney Fox decided it was too.
I think it's no.
You have to be here now.
You have to be on Twitch just in case.
I'm on Twitch now.
I don't want to get in trouble.
Also, I need to turn up the aircon.
It's so hot right now in my room.
Also, Yoshi, thank you for tier one, sub.
Thank you.
Let me go turn this up real quick.
I'm back.
I need to turn on the aircon.
It was so hot in my room.
I think it's just because I just came back from like, oh, I
need to wash my hands.
I had to wash my hands too because, like I said, carrying a
lot of stuff.
I have to pick up some packages too.
So I don't know, like, I don't know what's going on at the
package area.
Like, I'm pretty sure it's pretty dirty there.
100 biddies.
Thank you.
Sorry, sorry.
100 biddies.
Gordon.
Ah, 100 biddies.
Thank you.
Sorry.
Gordon, thank you for the 100 biddies.
Thank you.
Doki for the love of God.
Learn to limit your spending.
I'm trying.
She lied naturally.
Thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's see.
Let us, I chose some.
I actually, after that last stream, I went in and looked up
some good clips to do.
I pre-downloaded in advance, guys.
I did it.
I pre-prepped for this stream.
Oh my God.
What happened to you, Doki Bird?
Quick, it's a clone.
They took, they swapped the real Doki bird.
She would never prepare for a stream.
That's not Doki.
That's not the Doki I know.
Witch!
That's a pod person.
They abducted her.
Alright, let's see.
Choicer, voicer.
She's changed.
downloading clips in advance and also starting in time and
there was only one loop what did you do to her not my oh she
oh yeah the story i almost forgot about the story so i got
really scared because i was at the coffee shop and then
there were like uh there was like uh a group of ladies uh
sitting next to me oh wait oh my god wait this is so cool i
do not have hdhd hdhd's i do not have guys I sorry I opened
up Twitter naturally while I was trying to look up something
sorry I don't have HDMI I swear to God oh my god but look at
this guys bro I will actually wait I want this oh my god
wait this is a piggy bank uh a Jake piggy bank okay that's
pretty cool nobody uses coins anymore though i think piggy
banks are absolute in today's um um in today's world uh
because who who the fuck uses coins who uses coins for
anything um oh my god alec thank you for alic and celadon
thank you for the raid thank you thank you i hope you guys
had a great stream hello everybody i'm gonna be playing um
i'm gonna be playing choice or voice like the flavor of the
month game today but thank you so much for the rate i hope
you guys had a great time over on your streams um anyway but
yeah i don't i don't know if anybody actually used coins to
pay for stuff anymore it's all digital now it's all card
payments like there's like tap or venmo in america for you
americans it's like venmo or tap or card um maybe half i
guess is for Europe and NA I don't think anybody uses uh
coins anymore okay okay anyway back to my story um I was so
scared oh sorry I got distracted by the Jake piggy bank so
um I got really scared and nervous um because while when I
was ordering uh coffee and a dessert um there was a group of
ladies sitting next to me and they were all talking about
vtubers and their oh she's and talking about like e
specifically english vtubers too so i thought just like and
they had and the girls had like merch and everything to
vtubers because i glanced over and i recognized some of the
vtubers and i just like gulp that's it was so scary i was
just like oh my i hope i wasn't too loud when I was
ordering.
so I was just like, oh my, I just silently ate my dessert.
I didn't even dare to, I didn't even dare to open my phone
just in case they look over and just because like, they look
over and see like, like Discord messages, Jokey Bird
messaging.
Or Twitter.
Because like, you know, if I'm on Twitter, it'll be, and I
actually click my profile.
You're like, Jokey Bird.
Jokey Bird.
so I was just like oh I gotta get out of here I'm just like
oh fuck I gotta get out of here I gotta finish my dessert
and leave they don't know I'm actually a vtuber too oh yeah
no my wallpaper is me uh my entire my my lock screen
wallpaper is me and then my um my home screen wallpaper it's
me
I'm not incognito at all Like at one point I was like Hmm
should I have a dokeybird phone case too Maybe that's a
little too much Maybe yeah I'm my number one fan How
undercover of me Yeah I will I But luckily now that my My
mini My travel size dokeys are Are now available publicly
like uh display my jokie bird plushie too on my back on my
on my bag but that feel like it might be a little this is
why i don't take i don't show pictures of like the bags i
use or like the plushies on my bag because like like i don't
want people to know like because i always use like two bags
and like it i don't want to be able to like narrow it down
like that's her those are one of the two bags she uses
Mr. Broken Bond and Quail, thank you for gifting two tier
one subs to Alec and Seldon.
Thank you, thank you.
It's like, I've seen those bags, but that's why I don't show
pictures of what I use for like bags and stuff.
Because I'm like sweating.
I'm like, oh no.
Do they know I'm actually dokeybird?
Anyway, all right.
All right, choicer voicer.
It's time.
Okay, let me, let me...
Pull up the game now.
Sorry.
All right.
It's all right.
I still can't believe this is count in my rankings.
But no.
It's not fair.
I started my stream on time and I had one loop, but they
don't even put me in the leaderboards.
Papa Smurth, thank you for the hundred biddies.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
I love your dokey bird plush.
Why won't she respond?
Thank you for the hundred bitties.
Thank you.
Thank you I tell you guys.
Oh, I didn't tell you as a story before I I don't think I
did okay I don't remember what which one it was but I went
to a hall live concert and then um and then I was asked I
was standing I was sitting next to someone that tell you
guys the story before okay No, okay, I don't remember who I
told this story to okay I told this story to somebody, but I
don't remember who.
I think it was my manager.
Because I was like, I'm so scared.
So, and I got like, I got like, I went, I don't remember
which one it was.
There were so many.
And I don't remember when this was.
So I went to a Hololive concert.
It was like, um, don't remember when this was, by the way.
And, uh, and I like how steamed hams in the background.
me my my me and my steam hands my boy steamed hams but i
tell this story and also star wars but that's the two
screenshots of star wars and and so and then the guy next to
me was like who's your oh she
They're like, oh, who's your Oshi?
And I was just like, like, I'm like, I don't remember.
Okay, I think I said at that time, I was like, oh, it's Oli.
Because like, Oli was performing.
And then so I was just like, oh, it's Oli.
And she was like, oh, yeah, I love Oli too.
And then I was just like, yeah.
So, uh, yeah, yeah, it's my first time.
And then I ended the conversation.
And I, like, ended the conversation.
Didn't try to say anymore.
He must have been like, damn, this is such an awkward girl.
Like, damn, she must have been, she's so fucking awkward.
And I was, because I didn't want to say anything else.
I, I.
I remember I said Ollie and someone else I don't remember
who the other person was and I was just like and I just and
I just ended it there I just eat no yeah why are vtuber fans
so awkward I think I said I think I said uh I don't remember
I just remember I said like two or three other i think i
said two other names but i don't remember i just remembered
ollie only because i think she was performing at that time
and um so yeah that that's why i was like i'm it's like fear
and that's why i don't go to concerts anymore i don't i
haven't i think it was like my one and only vtuber concert
i've gone to other than my own concerts you know because I
have to be there, you know, I've had, I have to be on my
own.
I flew too close to the sun.
There's a pattern here.
I always fly too close to the sun with these things.
So I've only been to one VTuber concert.
That's not my own.
And it's, I, it's the only, it's going to be the only VTuber
concert I go to because I get, I'm too scared.
I'm too paranoid.
After that incident, I got too
I was like, I just, I did, I, it was too close.
Yeah.
It was, it was too close.
I didn't think I would have people talking to me.
I thought it was like quick in and out, you know?
I thought, I thought I'd be quick in and out.
Watch the concert.
Leave.
I didn't think I would have someone talk to me.
Yeah.
Yeah, one social interaction.
I was just like, oh my god.
Papa Smurfed.
Think about 150s.
But they were friendly.
They were very friendly, by the way.
It was just, I was just caught so off guard.
I was caught so off guard to that, like, Like, I just didn't
expect it.
I was not mentally prepared.
Yeah, I was like, how dare you be more extroverted than me?
How dare you?
It's not fair.
All right, let's actually play the game.
All right, let me see.
I don't know if I already put it in.
So I'm going to check.
Okay, I did it.
All right.
Let me deposit.
It's time to deposit the new clips.
What do you mean I have to be sociable?
All right.
How do I...
Let me open the folder again.
Where is the folder?
Oh, it customized.
Oh.
mod pack open folder all right there we go all right I got
the folder guys okay now let me deposit the clips we're
gonna go one by one but everybody was super friendly though
people were really really friendly I guess I don't even
remember when this was it was I don't remember when exactly
this was I remember telling the story to my manager because
I was freaking I was panicking I was like texting my
manager.
I was like, I was like, someone talk to me.
What do I do?
I was just like, my number one fear, social interaction in
public.
I was just like, calm down.
Just make sure you don't just just just change your voice a
little bit.
just just be friendly and change your voice a little bit and
like just don't talk too much and also don't laugh yeah that
too don't worry i was too fucking nervous to laugh
all right oh the first one oh my god there we go this was
what i wanted to do this one this was the one originally i
wanted to do This is the original clip I wanted to do.
Alright.
Let's see.
Alright, for those who don't know, don't worry.
You're gonna know.
Yes!
Yeah!
It's over, Anakin!
This is the original clip I wanted to do.
Alright, alright, I'm gonna start I'm gonna listen to a
little bit more.
It's over Anakin.
I have the high ground.
Don't try it.
Okay, it's just going to sound like me talking to me again.
Just so you guys know, I'm...
For those who don't know, I can only do two voices.
One is this voice right now, and the second voice is...
And I talk like a kid.
Like, I only know two voices.
So we're going to hear me talk to my inner demons right now.
It's like Doki versus Doki.
this is this is i'm having another another schizo episode
right now arguing with myself you and a chosen one you and a
chosen one you and a chosen one you and a chosen one you and
a chosen one it was said that you would destroy this if not
join them it was said that you would destroy this if not
join them said that you would destroy this if not join them
it was said that you would destroy this if not join them
bring balance to the forest not leave it in darkness bring
balance to the forest not leave it in darkness bring balance
to the forest not leave it in darkness You were my brother,
Anakin.
You were my brother, Anakin.
I loved you.
You underestimate my power.
Just as good as I remembered it, guys.
It really is just as great as I remember it.
I remembered it.
Oh, I cannot wait.
I cannot wait, guys.
You underestimate my power.
I hate you.
What the fuck do I do this?
I hate you!
Okay, okay.
This is the most emotion I've ever heard of this actor,
dude.
I hate you!
Exactly as I remembered.
I actually laughed at the end, too.
Fuck.
Give me a sec.
Also, sound is the sound team here?
Sound team.
You have to message me on Discord, but is the sound team
sound okay so far it's sound okay so far guys i need to be
sure all right oh yeah remember when i was 30 percent we're
moving up in the world everyone we're we're moving up all
right i'm so talented all right here we go here we fucking
go
Over, Anakin!
I have the high ground.
You underestimate my power.
Don't try it.
Oh, shit.
My legs.
Don't worry, I'll do extra sound effects too.
You were the chosen one.
It was said that you would destroy the Sith, not join them.
Bring balance to the force, not leave it in darkness.
Emotion.
Oh, I am going to cry.
It's so beautiful.
I hate you.
You are my brother, Anakin.
I loved you.
I hate you.
It's so beautiful.
I feel like I'm actually in the movie right now.
Oh my god.
Get her an Oscar nomination.
Get George Lucas on the line.
I will redub the entire Star Wars film for free.
I need to see this again.
It's over, Anakin.
Oh my god, you're right.
I have to hide.
Wait, wait, actually, let's go to the cinema.
Let's go to...
It's like we're watching an actual movie.
you guys it's over Anakin I have the high ground you
underestimate my power don't try it we will save the Star
Wars franchise down in front it's
even better a second time
You were the chosen one.
It was said that you would destroy the Sith, not join them.
Bring balance to the force, not leave it in darkness.
I hate you!
You are my brother, Anakin.
I loved you.
I hate you.
I hate you, Mom.
You don't know what it's like to be me.
You hear the pyramid so beautiful.
Oh, my God.
Someone click on, send us to George Lucas.
It's not a face, Mom.
You just don't know me.
That's all right.
That's what that sounds like.
That's what it sounds like to me.
Oh, shit, I forgot.
Oh, well.
Oh, it's, oh, it's saved.
It's saved, guys.
We have it there forever.
It's not.
You just don't understand me.
Thank you.
God.
Oh, I got a little worried there.
I thought we lost pure cinema.
I thought we lost a true art form today.
I just, I have the emotion part down.
I just don't have the, I just don't know how to play other
characters.
I, I just don't know.
Oh wait, I got one.
I got a good one.
Let's see.
Okay.
Wait, wait.
It is.
When I just found it, I just saw it too.
Where is it?
I literally just saw it.
Oh, this one.
This one.
Alright.
Dub mode.
Okay, wait.
Oops, I forgot to unzip it.
Forgot to extract this one.
Give me a sec, guys.
I just dragged and dropped.
Instead of unzipping it.
Uh...
Alright.
I was gonna say.
It's like watching the Mona Lisa being painted.
Alright.
Here's the second one.
Don't worry, I chose a good one.
Alright.
Whoa whoa whoa hey hey this is whoa whoa whoa hey hey this
is
You guys know what that you guys know what what this clip is
now It's a classic never watched Breaking Bad by the way
only saw the first episode My Breaking Bad knowledge is all
memes Whoa whoa whoa hey hey this is private property
Whoa, whoa, whoa, hey, hey, hey, this is private property.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, this is private
property.
Nope, nope, not interesting.
All right, all right, look, not touching.
Kate, not touching here.
all right all right look not touching kate not touching here
all right i i need i don't know how long his his part is but
we gotta go to scowler white yo oh shit oh no i accidentally
record i did get it all right all right look not touching
kate not touching here all right all right look not touching
Kate, not touching here.
Look, lady, whatever you're selling, I ain't buying, yo.
Look, look, lady, whatever you're selling, I ain't buying,
yo.
Look, lady, whatever you're selling, I ain't buying, yo.
Seriously?
Okay.
I think so, yeah.
No more marijuana.
I just realized it's 18 clips.
Give me, sorry, I got 30 clips.
All right.
We're gonna have to fast track this.
We got speed run this guys.
Little commentary right now.
We got speed run this.
All right.
Here we go.
I think so.
Yeah.
No more marijuana.
I think so.
Yeah.
No more marijuana.
I think so.
Yeah.
No more marijuana.
I think so.
Yeah.
No more marijuana.
I think so.
Yeah.
No more marijuana.
I think so.
Yeah.
No more marijuana.
i can dig it i can i can dig it i can i can dig it okay okay
okay excuse me that's she has 10 plus oh my god she has 20
lines that's the long skylar white yo how long does she go
for
Excuse me.
You.
Yes, you.
May I talk to you.
You.
Yes, you.
May I talk to you.
You.
Yes, you.
May I talk to you.
You.
Yes, you.
May I talk to you.
Just a minute, I want to talk to you.
Hey, don't touch me.
Do not touch me.
Well, my name is Skylar Whiteyo.
Yes!
My husband is Walter White, yo.
This is what I'm talking about.
How is that clip 17 out of 30?
That is the part.
She said the thing.
We need our vine boom.
I need a sound board to do a vine boom.
Well, my name is Skylar White, yo.
My husband is Walter White, yo.
Uh-huh.
Well, my name is Skylar White Yo.
My husband is Walter White Yo.
Uh-huh.
Well, my name is Skylar White Yo.
My husband is Walter White Yo.
Uh-huh.
Wait, I got it.
I got it.
I know what to do.
I know what to do, guys.
Well, well, my name is Skyler White, yo.
My husband is Walter White, yo.
Uh-huh.
I got time and better.
Give me a sec.
I need time and a bit.
my god where is it it's so hard to do manually guys well
my name is skylor white yo my husband is walter white yo
well
my name is skylor white yo my husband well my name is skylor
white yo my husband is He told me everything.
He told me everything.
That's right.
And just so you know, my brother-in-law is a DEA agent, and
I will not hesitate to call him.
Not if I have to.
Understood?
This is your one and only warning.
Do not sell marijuana to my husband.
I mean it I mean it I mean it don't call our house again
don't call our house again you stay away from him or you
will be one sorry individual is the Skyler white yo just one
part like just clip 17 out of 30 that's it I thought there
would be more.
For some reason, in my head, it felt like she said like 20
more lines.
It was just so iconic.
You stay away from him, or you will be one sorry individual.
You stay away from him, from him or you will be one sorry
individual you get me you get me you
can take it
where is the wonderful from it's like it's like a tiny ass
waveform where is it you can dig it wonderful i'm just i'm
just gonna i'm yoloing that
You can take it.
I know that it's any of my business, but you might want to
consider a different line of work.
don't yeah like like oh sorry zero like what do you want me
to do here what do you want me to do right here i don't want
no what you it was nothing i had nothing to work with all
right here we go here let's see what this is gonna go
excuse me excuse me you yes you may i talk to you whoa whoa
whoa hey this is private property just a minute i want to
talk to you nope no not interested come on don't touch me do
not touch me all right all right look not touching you okay
not touching look lady whatever you're selling i am buying
yo well my name is skylor white yo my husband's That's
right.
And just so you know, my brother-in-law is a DEA agent, and
I will not hesitate to call him.
Not if I have to.
Understood?
This is your one and only warning.
But it was so quiet.
So marijuana to my husband.
I thought it'd be louder.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
I mean it.
Don't call her house again.
him or you'll be one sorry individual you get me I uh think
so yeah um no more marijuana mm-hmm again I can take it you
can take it wonderful I didn't know what she said it I had
no point of reference not that's not any of my business but
you might want to consider uh line of work okay how was I
supposed to know there was nothing there there was no
fucking sound I can't believe it was just that one line that
I'm scared of what yo excuse me excuse me You.
Yes, you.
Yeah, I got the important part right, though.
This entire stream is just jokie talking to jokie.
Just a minute.
I want to talk to you.
Nope.
No, not interesting.
Come on.
Don't touch me.
Do not touch me.
All right, all right.
Look, not touching you, okay?
Not touching.
Look, lady, whatever you're selling, I ain't buying, yo.
Well, my name is Skylar White, yo.
My husband's Walter White, yo.
I did have time to do the second one.
he told me everything seriously that's right and just so you
know my brother-in-law is a DEA agent and I will not
hesitate to call him not if I have to understood this is
your one and only warning do not sell marijuana to my
husband okay I mean it don't call our house again you stay
away from him or you'll be one sorry oh my god that's emmy
emmy nominated actress dokey bird right there you see felt
that i felt like i was about to cry for real i can i can dig
it you can dig it wonderful
do not sell marijuana to my husband not that's not any of my
business but You might want to consider a different line of
work.
Okay.
Cinema.
I should have been up there with the Breaking Bad cast.
Oh my god.
Why did you make her so...
Isn't she like...
Like...
A bitch?
I was just I was just channeling my Karen right there is
this that's all I know I just remember like the memes always
call her a bitch like like call her like a bit bitchy and
Karen like not a bitch just a suburban white woman so like
what's the difference.
She just didn't want her husband to sell drugs, Stokie.
Soya, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
We had a great stream.
Adonite, thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Suji, thank you for the tier one sub.
Thank you.
Why is she such a Karen?
Oh my god.
She's just trying to... Oh my god.
Let her husband sell drugs.
oh my god why is she such a bitch because her because her
husband just wants to sell drugs i don't understand oh yes
this is what i wanted this was the original one that i
wanted to do too the original one all right you ready this
is the one i wanted to do how many clips is this let's find
out oh yeah has the sound been has the sound been good so
far my auto team maybe bring down oh for bgm all right i'll
bring down the bgm a little it was at 13.
all right here we go
um all right all right here we go this is the one i wanted
to do in the first stream i am so lonely
okay give me a sec we'll turn okay we'll move it i am so
lonely Okay, give me a sec.
We'll turn this one because he's so lonely, Doki.
He's so lonely.
I am so lonely.
I don't know if I can do this.
I don't know if I can... I don't know if I can, like,
capture the ride.
emotion this this is this is this would might be my hardest
challenge yes guys this is my hardest challenge I am so
lonely i am so lonely I am so lonely all the other filter
minds are scared of me
No image.
All the other Viltramites are scared of me.
No one talks to me.
No one wants to be my friend.
They think I am unstable.
for conquest.
I actually don't remember.
Give me a second.
Was it like, um, what was that conquest line that I did?
What was it?
What was that line I did last time?
I forgot this iconic line.
I did sort of do a, oh, San ready for my rival dragon.
Was that the voice?
San ready for my rival dragon.
That's the voice, right?
I tried to a mumbie yeah all right okay i gotta i gotta like
channel that
no one wants to be my friend they think i am unstable no one
wants to be my friend they think i am unstable no one wants
to be my friend they think i am unstable no one wants to be
my friend they think i am unstable no one wants to be my
friend they think i am unstable they send me from planet to
planet committing atrocities in their name they send me from
planet to planet committing atrocities in their name they
send me from planet to planet they send me from planet to
planet committing atrocities in their As I get better at it,
they fear me more and more.
And as I get better at it, they fear me more and more.
I am a victim of my own success.
victim of my own success I am a victim I am a victim of my
own success
conquest conquest conquest
conquest I don't even get a real name I don't even get a
real name.
I don't even get a real name.
Only a purpose.
I am capable of so much more and no one sees it.
I am capable of so much more.
and no one sees it.
Some days I feel so alone I could cry, but I don't.
I never do.
Because what would be the point?
Not a single person in the entire universe would care.
Not a single person in the entire...
Take it to your grave.
Angry noises Take it to your grave That's why I choke him,
right?
Yeah What is that?
That's him choking him, right?
That's God goes with choking him, right?
Take it to your grave Yeah?
So I just do choke, like Ugh!
Take it to your grave.
Okay,
the ending, I sort of just trolled the ending part.
I sort of trolled it, so you'll see.
You'll see what I mean.
I sort of trolled it.
I'm sort of funny
background noise.
Like, what do you want me to do?
Lonely
What is the fact?
I'm committing atrocities in their name And as I get better
at it They fear me more and more I am a victim of my own
conquest I don't even get a real name only a purpose I am
capable of so much more no one sees it some days I feel so
alone I could cry but I don't I never do because what would
be the point not a single person in the entire universe
would care
sorry take it to your grave
What did you do?
I didn't know!
So, thank you for the dear one.
So, thank you, thank you.
Okay, wait, let me second.
All right, well, maybe if I turn this, okay, this one has
120.
Remember, 120.
Maybe.
Is this less more quiet?
Yeah.
No.
I am so lonely.
Why is this not working?
Okay, okay.
Oh, the other filter might be scared of me.
Oh, my God.
So loud.
Wait, what was this?
I forgot what this one was.
be my friend.
I think I am unstable.
What was this at?
They sent me from what was this at?
I don't remember.
Oh no.
What was voice to that?
I messed it with the settings.
I am a victim of my own success.
I don't remember.
I don't even get a real name.
Only a purpose I am capable of so much more No one sees it
Some days I feel so Oh it was 75, okay thank you I never do
Why is, if only I was allowed It would be the point Not a
single person in the entire universe I'm just watching for
the ending The ending was the best part
Take it to your grave
Okay, all right, this was at 110, boys, this was at 75.
Okay.
It said angry toys.
I didn't know what to do.
I had no visuals of when he started doing, like, all I grew
up, I was like, okay, he's choking him.
So I was like, RAR, RAR, RAR, RAR, RAR, RAR, R, R, R, R, R,
R, R, R, R, R, R, R.
That's all I could think of.
That's all I could think of, of like, what can I do in that
situation, you know?
But, yeah.
but yeah that was good though that was good Gordon thank you
for the 100 videos thank you thank you after the alpha
roleplay from yesterday I'm no longer seeing a pattern with
that girl thank you anonymous thank you for tier one sub the
conquest GXM thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank
you award-winning voice acting right there all right all
right next up Next clip.
Will Doki actually use a put on a voice?
Will it still just be Doki Bird?
Let's, oh, you know what?
I got another good one.
Next clip.
All right.
This one's a good one.
This one's a good one, guys.
Don't worry.
I got a classic!
There we go.
You're impossibly fast and strong.
Your skin is pale.
white and ice cold.
Your skin is pale white and ice cold.
Your eyes change color.
And sometimes you speak like, like you're from a different
time.
And sometimes you speak like like you're from a different
You never eat or drink anything.
You don't go out in the sunlight.
never eat or drink anything you don't go out in the sunlight
you never eat or drink anything you don't go out in the
sunlight how old are you
how old are you how old are you how long have you been 17
i think that's what he goes for a while that's what he's
like fbi this is the moment the FBI comes in.
FBI open up.
This guy's been 17 a little too long.
It might be a little too long.
You might technically be 17.
But whoa.
By the way, for those who don't know, Twilight was written
by a Mormon.
So like there's a lot of like religious stuff in twilight if
you actually like look into it and analytically so like he
can't by the way okay so the funny thing about it is that
like um the whole like you know for mormons it's like oh no
sex before marriage so like it's all like super horny shit
but they're like we can't do anything so like basically
technically um edward is like has been a virgin for like a
while so he's yeah so so because it's like the she's like
upkeeping the Mormonism in twilight Edward has technically
been a virgin for a while
and also you know the iconic scene where like it's like the
the fan um the fans blowing in like the fans blowing in and
then Edward is freaking out when Bella just popped like when
Bella and the room do you know the reason why he's like
freaking out in that in that clip but he's like whoa what
when he sees Bella it's because Bella was on her period it's
because like for those people don't realize this but if you
read the book or like remember the context wise she was on
her period and Edward was like whoa that's why that's why we
got the freaky scene Of like Edward freaking out in science
class.
Yeah.
The blood food was too much for him.
So that's why.
Yes.
Let me give you guys.
Let me show you the clip of it.
Of Edward.
Seeing Bella for the first time.
Wow, Doki.
You surprisingly know so much.
about Twilight.
I had to fit in.
I pretended.
So in volleyball club, Twilight was a huge thing when I was
in my volleyball team.
And like everybody was reading it on my team and I wanted to
fit in.
I didn't want to be the outsider.
So I bought the book too because everybody would be like,
are you Team Jacob or Team Edward?
And then I would be like, what's that?
It's like, oh, it's Twilight.
Everybody's reading it.
Like they'll be reading it practices and stuff.
So then I was like, you know, so I didn't wanna be left up
because everybody, like I wanted to conform to society, you
know, I didn't wanna be the fucking weirdo.
So I had to assimilate into the team and I bought the book
and I read it, but I thought it was so ass.
So like I read the first book and I'm like, oh my gosh, I'm
totally t- I don't remember.
I think I was team Edward.
I was like, yeah, I'm totally team Edward.
Like, oh my God and then I would bring the book with me to
practices and everything and like oh my god did you read the
second book yet and I'll be like oh yeah I'm reading it
right now I just I just started and then what I did was
because everybody would bring their books and everything too
um everyone was like bringing their books to practices and
everything and I I had to you know I had to not be I wanted
to like I didn't want them to know I was larping I didn't
want them to know Tending to be, like, part of the in-group
just to fit in and everything.
So I also, I had to buy the books and I brought it with me
to practices and everything, but I could only read the first
book because it was so, it was so bad.
I was just like, this is, I can't, I cannot read more.
So I finished the first book, but I still had to kept going
because all the girls were talking about, did you read that
second book yet?
And then nobody talked about, oh my God, did you, uh, oh my
God, what did you think about?
You know, they would quiz each other about stuff, but we'll
not quiz each other, but they'll talk about some of the
scenes.
So what I did was I'll buy the other books, like the second,
the New Moon, Eclipse, whatever the fuck, I don't remember
what they're called.
I remember the Eclipse and New Moon.
I'll buy all the books, and then I'll read the Wikipedia
article of the entire plot summary.
And I'll go on Wikipedia, read the plot summary, the
synopsis of all the books.
and get like cliff notes or whatever and then just like
that's how i blend it right in like so they'll ask us like
oh my god i can't believe this happened oh my god i can't
believe jacob imprinted on blah blah blah blah or like oh
yeah so so that's why i know a lot about twilight right i
know too much about twilight all right let me find the
edward scene where she meets edward for the first time all
right all right here we go oh it's this one all right here
i'll give you guys a um all right so it is all right it is
243 guys is this scene at At 243, this is the scene.
This is also, but I had to, I had to pretend because in the
volleyball team, it was all the popular girls, too.
It was all the popular girls like the, because everybody
that was in the volleyball team were the popular girls and
so I didn't want to, you know, because I didn't want to be,
I didn't want to be the weirdo that didn't read twilight Oh,
it blocked it unfortunate, but if you are if you can if you
can access this link it's 243 and that's why he reacted like
that It's because she the blood moon was on him and that's
why he reacted like that
All right back to doving
How long you've been 17?
Hey, hey, it was not smut.
They didn't do anything until they got married.
And it took three books for them to get married.
It wasn't allowed.
How long you've been 17?
Bro, this oh my god i'm gonna sound so oh do not clip this i
turn off clipping for this oh my god this sounds oh all
right here's the bone dragon series
oh my god even i'm like oh
i know what you are i know what you are I know what you are.
I know what you are.
Vampire.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you heard it?
Ah, frightened cats!
Oh.
No.
no no no you won't hurt me you won't hurt me you won't hurt
me you won't hurt me 17
the fact that Robert Patterson is playing what's his name
the PDF under yeah he's playing Chris Hatcher right now he's
yeah he's what a perfect segue to chris hanson chad thank
you for the raid thank you thank you i hope you had a great
stream we are dubbing twilight and i forgot how many moans
and gasps there are in here uh it's a little odd I forgot
how sensual this clip is.
I only remember how long you've been 17.
That's all I can remember.
I was 17.
A while.
See it.
Out loud.
He's such a creep.
I can't believe I was Team Edward while I lied.
Can't believe I lied instead of I was Team Edward.
I should have chose Jacob.
Say it.
Never mind.
Later on you find out Jacob imprinted on a child.
So like, they're all pretty creepy.
Say it.
Are you afraid?
Then ask me the most basic question.
What do we eat?
Nice.
Um, I don't know why I want nice to be.
All right.
No, I'm going to be so embarrassed.
I'm going to be so embarrassed.
You know, people like me, they'll be like, oh say it say it
or like they'll use like actual voices but i'm just myself
so i right i should i should have used voices i should have
like i should have used voices i should not fucking use my
own voice i should have actually i should actually try to
put on a voice this time i'll be like say it what am i
Oh my god.
Oh no.
You're impossibly fast and strong.
Your skin is pale white and ice cold.
Your eyes change color.
And sometimes you speak like...
Like you're from a different time.
You never eat or drink or anything.
You don't go in the sunlight.
The anime dub.
Twilight the anime.
How long are you?
I'm 17.
How long you've been?
A while.
I know what you are.
Say it.
Oh my god.
Out loud.
Say it.
Don't keep grooming Doki right now.
Vampire.
Are you afraid?
I can't.
No.
then ask me the most basic question what do we eat
what do you order what the fuck it just stops
oh my god oh my god oh yeah it's just the anime adaptation
of the and the dub it just stops You who entered me?
Oh, I'm not replaying that.
Doki, you literally asked for that.
Doki, Riz, that's not Riz.
Bro, that's not Riz.
All right, get me out of here.
Get me, get me out of here.
all right next next clip next clip guys home to fair the
reason why okay i know a lot of people when the movie came
out a lot of people criticize uh kristen stewart and robert
paddison's acting but you guys have no idea how bad like
they had nothing to work with like they got their bag The
thing is, they got their bag from doing Twilight so they
could do any movies they want.
So they went straight into indie films right after because
they already got so much money from being on such a big
franchise and they have royalties too.
To basically, they get royalties forever from Twilight.
So they could do indie films and do what actually start
acting.
If you've read the books, Bella has fucking no character.
She's literally a self-insert for the writer, She was like
Stephanie Myers was so fucking repressed because like She
was a repressed housewife.
She poured it all into Twilight and it was like a
self-insert She had no personality whatsoever like Kristen
Stewart had nothing to work with and then Robert Patterson
had to pretend to be like this Like not a creep by the way
not a creepy guy Who has been 17 for a while yeah yeah she's
who just try to make robert patterson work and try to not be
that creepy so he had really had nothing to work with here
and that's why like the acting is like all over the place
like not a creep just eternally 17 uh
all right let's see it What else can I do?
Let's see.
What's this?
I don't know if I should do this.
Alright, I'll do...
Okay, wait.
Alright, I'm trying to figure out the next one.
Oh.
Alright, we'll do this one.
This one might...
I always quote this clip all the time.
I hope it's not that long.
I know the scene itself is fucking long as hell.
But I always quote this.
I always quote this movie all the time.
I hope I can do it justice.
All right.
I love this movie so much.
I love this scene in particular from this movie.
Now, guys, what movie is she talking about?
You fight with the strength of many men tonight.
What out of 65?
All right.
Here we go.
It's worth it.
It's going to be worth it.
Guys, this is a good clip.
I always quote this.
It's a classic.
All right, here we go.
We got speedrun.
This is a long time.
This is a long clip.
Let me hydrate real quick.
It's worth it, though.
This is a good thing.
This one is worth it.
All right.
You fight with the strength of many men tonight.
I am Arthur, king of the Britons.
Arthur, king of the Britons.
King of the Britons.
Sound guy, remember this.
I boosted all the way up.
You need to help me remember this because I could barely
hear it.
I am
Arthur, king of the Britons.
I seek the finest and the bravest knights in the land to
join me in my court at Camelot.
You have proved yourself worthy.
Will you join me?
worthy will you join me you have proved yourself worthy will
you join me you make me sad you make me sad you make me sad
so be it come Patsy so be it come Patsy so be it come Patsy
what
what what I have no quarrel with you goods But I must cross
this bridge.
What happened there?
Why is there back?
Right there.
I have
no quarrel with you good tonight.
But I have no quarrel with you good tonight.
But I must cross this bridge.
I command you as king of the Britons to stand aside.
So be it.
Now stand aside, worthy adversary.
A scratch, your arms off.
But what's that then?
You liar!
Come on!
Victory is mine!
We can't be lord, that in thy life We can't be lord, that in
thy life We can't be lord, that in thy life
what what what what you're indeed brave tonight but the
fight is mine you're indeed brave tonight but the fight is
mine you're indeed brave tonight but the fight is mine look
you're stupid bastard you've got no arms left i'm only at 21
guys i'm Guys, guys, put out the chair.
It's gonna be a while.
It'll be worth it, guys.
It'll be worth it.
Lay out the chair.
It's gonna be a while.
Look, you're stupid bastard.
You've got no arms left.
Look, I'll have your leg.
Right.
Right!
You what?
What are you gonna do, bleed on me?
You're a loony.
Compassive.
None shall pass.
All right, we gotta have the echo here.
Okay, muffles sound.
What makes me echoey here?
Is it a megaphone?
Wait, guys.
Okay.
Not this.
Reverb?
Does this make me sound like it?
Does this make me sound like it or no?
Yeah?
Kinda?
Sort of?
Okay, maybe we do this.
Ceiling fresh... Though I don't understand any of this.
Maybe we don't do this.
Get a cup?
Wait, okay, wait.
I do have a... I do think I have a cup.
Uh...
How about this?
None shall pass.
Does that work?
Wait.
None shall pass.
Does that work?
Is that good?
Does that, does that work?
Okay.
All right, we'll do this.
None shall pass.
The first one sounded better?
Like this?
Wait.
Does that sound better?
The megaphone was better?
Like this?
The cup?
Oh, the cup without the reverb?
Cup?
Okay, this is with reverb.
This is with reverb, guys.
This one.
It's with reverb.
This is without reverb.
Guys, without reverb.
No reverb?
Drinking my water, too.
No reverb.
All right, all right.
Okay, I got you.
I got you.
None shall pass.
Then you shall pass.
die.
Then you shall die.
I move for no man.
Yeah, don't worry.
I'm halfway there.
35 out of 65.
I had to do it.
I always quote this particular scene every time.
It's just all grunts from the black night.
It is but a scratch.
No, it isn't.
I've had worse.
Are they worse?
Come on, you pansy!
What the fuck are we?
Okay.
Alright, give me a- let me hydrate real quick.
all right here we go I
fucked up I didn't record that part I clicked next to
accidentally I forgot to I'm
not I can't I cannot do this again we it's just gonna be
silence it's hard I'm on my fucking I'm I'm I'm trying to
like dump this while holding a cup in front of me.
Come on, then.
How about you?
Oh, I don't know, eh?
Oh, I don't know, I don't know, eh?
Yes, I have.
Just a flesh wound.
Fat chicken.
Chicken!
That chicken!
Frights!
I'll do you for that!
Come here!
I'm invincible!
The Black Knight always triumphs!
How about you?
Come on, then.
What?
All right.
We call it a draw.
Oh, oh, I see.
Running away, eh?
You yellow bastards, come back here and take what's coming,
do you?
You yellow bastard, come back here and take what's coming to
you.
I'll bite your legs off.
My best one yet, guys.
My best one so far.
I think that was the best one I've done.
Which one was it?
Where I forgot to dub it.
Is it?
What?
What did I even say?
Where is it?
actually accidentally dubbed it a little.
I don't even know.
I might have.
Oh, I never seen a zero in.
Oh, there it is.
Isn't this?
There's so many zeros.
Wait, there's so many.
That actually dubbed it a little bit.
Who knows?
We're gonna find out.
night where is the i am arthur king of the britons
i seek the finest and bravest knights in the land to join me
in my court of camelot
you have proved yourself worthy will you join me i can't i
can't do a british accent guys be sad so be it come patsy
none shall pass what none shall pass i have no quarrel with
you good sir knight i must cross this bridge then you shall
die i command you as king of the britons to stand aside i
move for no man so be it
I feel like an action figure time sounds like when my action
figure is now
stand aside worthy adversary this is but scratch a scratch
your arms off no it isn't what's that then a bad words
No, this is not this is the one where I did it three is mine
We thank thee lord that in my Come on then what have at you
You are indeed brave sir knight but the fight is mine Oh had
enough eh Look you stupid bastard you've got no arms left
Yes I am Look just a flesh wound Stop that!
Chicken!
Look, I have your leg!
Right!
Right, I'll do you for that!
You what?
Come here!
What are you going to do, bleed on me?
I'm invincible!
You're a loony!
The black knight always triumphs!
Come at you!
Come on, then!
Oh.
All right.
We'll call it a draw.
Come, Patsy.
Oh, I see.
Running away, you yellow bastard.
Come back here, take what's coming to you.
That's good.
I'll bite your legs off.
That was good.
That was a good one.
That was worth 65 clips.
My 17%...
The M, I'm sorry, my, yeah, my, yeah, that was where 64
clips, guys.
It was, it was so good.
I should watch it in the cinema.
I, let's actually watch it in the movies.
You fight with the strength of many men, sir knight.
I am Arthur, king of the Britons.
I wonder who they got a voice acting in this movie, guys.
I see the finest and bravestness in the land.
I wonder if she has an IMDb.
Join me in my court of Camelot.
You have proved yourself worthy.
Will you join me?
You make me sad.
I wonder if she ever won an Emmy before.
None shall pass.
What?
I have no quarrel with you, good sir, knight.
I must cross this bridge.
Then you shall die.
I command you as king of the Britons to stand aside.
I move for no man.
Oh, man, that picture was so good.
Whoever did the voice edits for this.
Oh, man.
They should give her a raise.
Then you shall die.
Now stand aside, worthy adversary.
a scratch your arms off no it isn't what's that then i do
feel like i'm playing with action figures right now scratch
it's just a scratch yeah just a flesh wound victory is mine
we thank the lord that in my come on then i love that part
how about you
but the fight is mine.
Oh, had enough, eh?
Look, you stupid bastard, you've got no arms left.
Yes, I have.
Look, just a flesh wound.
Look, stop that.
Chicken, chicken.
Look, I'll have your leg.
Right.
Right, I'll do you for that.
You what?
Come here.
What are you going to do, bleed on me?
I'm invincible.
You're a loony.
The black knight always triumphs.
Have at you!
Come on, then.
Alright.
We'll call it a draw.
Come, Patsy.
Oh, I see.
Running away, you yellow bastards.
Come back here and take what's coming to you.
I'll bite your legs off.
Beautiful.
That was beautiful, guys.
Oh, my.
It was worth paying $80 an IMAX ticket.
to see that film guys oh my god whoever they got to for the
hd remaster uh redubbing of monte python in the search for
the holy grail whoever they got damn she's talented i hope
they paid her lots and lots of money and royalties yeah the
voice actor wow all the the two voice actors they they got
for that wow truly an amazing accomplishment in cinema right
there beautiful all right let's see what else what else do i
want to do we'll do two more what range i know she has such
amazing range too all right well dude i know this is a
classic that everybody always wants me to um has always
wanted me to voice act because i somehow sound like this
person i don't know i don't really see it but i'll do it
wait how long is this how long how many all right let's see
how long is this number 15 burger king foot lettuce all
right here we go sorry i had to ask i was like sound guy
what was it and i realized he already sent it to me we go is
it loud number 15 is this too loud king foot lettuce is the
clip played back too loud or is it okay is it fine it's fine
all right here we go number 15 burger king foot lettuce
number 15 burger king foot lettuce the last thing you'd want
in your burger king burger is someone's foot fungus the last
thing you'd want in your burger king burger is someone's
foot fungus the The last thing you'd want in your Burger
King burger is someone's foot fungus.
But as it turns out, that might be what you get.
A 4chanter uploaded a photo anonymously to the site.
A four-channer uploaded a photo anonymously to the site
Showcasing his feet in a plastic bin of lettuce Showcasing
his feet in a plastic bin of lettuce Showcasing his feet in
a plastic bin of lettuce With the statement, this is the
lettuce you eat at Burger King With the statement, this is
the lettuce you eat at Burger King With the statement, this
is the lettuce you eat at Burger King Burger King.
Admittedly, he had shoes on, but that's even worse.
I might scrap this.
This 20.
I don't, I did 65 and I'm tired.
I'm tired now.
You can lock in.
little liar.
I'm so tight.
I did 65.
I'm just like, I'm giving it all she got, Captain.
I, can we hear the opening live?
I'll give you the opening live.
Guys, watch.
Okay, we'll give you the opening live.
Admit.
The post went live at 1138 pm on july 16th the and a mere 20
minutes later the burger king in question was alerted to the
rogue employee and a mere 20 at least i hope he's rogue at
how did it happen how well the bk employee had it removed
the exif data from the uploaded photo which suggested the
culprit was Ohio which this was at 1147 three minutes later
at 1150 the Burger King branch address was posted it's the
screams the screams with wishes of happy unemployment I was
yelling with my heart five minutes later the news station
was contacted by another 4chanter five and three minutes
later at 1158 a link was posted bk's tell us about us online
form yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it was too much photo
otherwise known as exhibit a was attached the cleveland
scene magazine contacted the bk in question the next day
we're almost there when questioned the breakfast shift
manager said oh i know who that is mystery solved by 4chan
he now we can all go back to eating our fast food i didn't
even realize there was more of this all right here we go i
did better this one i did better i did better in this one
then the black night better by doing less Critics, they
don't understand this.
They don't get us, guys.
Number 15, Burger King Foot Lettuce.
The last thing you want in your Burger King Burger is
someone's foot fungus.
But as it turns out, that might be what you get.
A 4-channer uploaded a photo anonymously to the site,
showcasing his feet in a plastic bin of lettuce, with a
statement.
This is the lettuce you eat at Burger King.
And then I stopped.
Do you hear it?
Number 15.
Burger King foot lettuce.
The last thing you want in your Burger King burger is
someone's foot fungus.
But as it turns out, that might be what you get.
A four-channer uploaded a photo anonymously to the site
showcasing his feet in a plastic bin of lettuce with a
statement.
This is the lettuce you eat at Burger King.
Silence.
Dramatic pause.
We'll never let dramatic soon.
Silence is so omnibus right now.
What about it?
Oh, you hear me?
laughing because I'm fucking plowing through it
it's still like lag it's like sorry we're disconnected from
the feed right now I'm like the four chat creepy pasta yeah
the BGM
let us take
You're waiting for it.
Oh, 20%, though.
20%.
All right, one last one.
I'll call it here after this one.
All right.
Oh, it's hard to pick.
Okay, we'll do a short one.
We're going to do a short one, guys.
Let's see.
I know some of these are so long, so I'm going to...
I'm gonna do a short one.
I can't do a long one.
The Monty Python would be the longest one.
Something epic.
Oh, I'll show you something epic.
There'll be a fast one.
I know this one's short, too.
I know this one's short.
It's 30!
It's bullshit.
I did not hit her.
I did not.
Oh, hi, Mark.
thought it was one line i thought it's the full scene all
right i did not hit her it's not true it's bullshit i did
not hit her i did not oh hi mark okay wait let's just
i did not hit her it's not true it's bullshit i did not hit
her i did not oh hi mark oh i did not hit her it's not true
it's bullshit i did not hit her i did not Oh, hi, Mark.
I have a problem with Lisa.
She said that I hit her.
No, it's not true.
Don't even ask.
What's new with you?
No, it's not true.
Don't even ask.
What's new with you?
No, it's not true.
Don't even ask.
What's new with you?
Oh.
Yeah.
What makes you say that?
I don't have to worry about that because Lisa is loyal to
me.
Yeah.
It's straight.
What a story, Mark?
Yeah, you can go straight.
I'm so happy I have you as my best friend, and I love Lisa
so much.
Yeah.
Okay, guys, I hope it doesn't sound too stupid.
I hope, okay.
I don't know if I could capture the essence of the room,
guys.
I'm so happy I have you as my best friend, and I love Lisa
so much.
Yeah.
I'm so happy I have you as my best friend, and I love Lisa
so much.
Yeah.
Well, maybe you should have a girl, Mark.
Well, what happened?
Betty?
That's her name?
Well, what happened?
Remember Betty?
That's her name?
Well, what happened?
Remember Betty?
That's her name?
Yeah?
That's too bad.
My Lisa is great when I can get it.
um that's too bad my lisa is great when i can get it that's
too bad my lisa is great when i can get it it seems to me
like you're the expert mark it seems to me like you're the
expert mark it seems to me like you're the expert mark
what's bothering you mark okay i might chat i might have
been chatteling a little bit of eric Cartman.
I'm I just realized that while I did that.
Okay, it might sound a little like Eric Cartman Just just a
little bit
It's just just a little bit guys
What's bothering you mark?
This is not what I'm no definitely not an expert Johnny
what's bothering you mark like okay.
I'm gonna go with what I hear I'm gonna go with what I hear
What's bothering you mark?
Do you do you have some secret?
Forget it.
Why don't you talk to me?
Why?
Forget it, dude.
Is it some secret?
No, forget.
I'll talk to you later.
Do you do you have some secret?
Forget it.
Why?
Forget it, dude.
Is it some secret?
No, forget.
Do you do you have some secret?
Why don't you tell me?
Forget it, dude.
Is it some secret?
No, forget.
I'll talk to you later.
Oh, hey, Johnny.
What's up?
Well, did you?
What?
Well, I'm just sitting up here thinking, you know.
I got a question for you.
Yeah.
Well, I'm just sitting up here thinking, you know?
I got a question for you.
Yeah.
You think girls like to cheat like guys do?
I've never watched the room, by the way.
What is the sentence?
You think girls like to cheat like guys do?
I don't know.
I'm just...
I'm just thinking.
I don't know.
I'm just...
I'm just thinking.
Yeah, man, you never know.
People are very strange these days.
I used to know a girl.
She had a dozen guys.
One of them found out about it, beat her up so bad she ended
up in a hospital on Guerrero Street.
Yeah, man, you never know.
People are very strange these days.
I used to know a girl.
She had a dozen guys.
One of them found out about it, beat her up so bad she ended
up in a hospital on Guerrero Street.
Yeah, man, you never know.
People are very strange these days.
She had a dozen guys.
One of them found out about it, beat her up so bad she ended
up in a hospital on Guerrero Street.
Yeah, you can say that again.
Yeah, man.
Yeah, you are very lucky.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe you're right.
Maybe I have one already.
I don't know yet.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe you're right.
Maybe I have one already.
I don't know yet.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe you're right.
Maybe I have one already.
I don't know yet.
Betty?
Yeah, we don't see each other anymore.
You know, she wasn't any good in bed.
She was beautiful, but we had too many arguments.
Yes.
There's too many arguments, no.
She wasn't any good in bed.
Wait, what?
She was in bed?
Yeah, we don't see each other anymore.
You know, she wasn't any good in bed.
Oh!
What?
All right.
Yeah, we don't see each other anymore.
You know, she wasn't any good in bed.
She was beautiful, but we had too many arguments.
Oh.
Oh man, I just can't figure women out.
Sometimes they're just too smart.
Sometimes they're flat out stupid.
Other times they're just evil.
It seems...
Oh man, I just can't figure women out.
Sometimes they're just too smart.
Sometimes they're flat out stupid.
Other times they're just evil.
It seems...
Oh man, I just can't figure women out.
Sometimes they're just too smart.
Sometimes it's flat out stupid.
Other times they're just evil.
It seems...
No.
Definitely not an expert, Johnny.
Nothing, man.
Get it.
Why?
Forget it, dude.
Is it some secret?
No, forget.
I'll talk to you later.
Get it.
Why?
forget it dude is it some secret no forget i'll talk to you
later get it why don't you why forget it dude is it some
secret no forget i'll talk to you later get it why don't you
why forget it dude is it some secret no forget i'll talk to
you later get it why don't you why forget it dude get it why
don't you why forget it dude is it some secret no forget
i'll talk to you later
Apparently, it's fine.
It's apparently better than the Black Knight again.
All right, here we go.
Okay, I might have channeled a little bit, accidentally
channeled a little bit of Eric Carmen while I was doing
Tommy.
All right, all right, I'm a little worried too.
I'm a little worried with how I sound like for him.
I'm just a little worried.
I did not hit her.
It's not true.
It's bullshit.
I did not hit her.
I did not.
Oh, hi, Mark.
Oh, hey, Johnny, what's up?
I have a problem with Lisa.
She says I hit her.
What?
Well, did you?
No, it's not true.
Don't even ask.
What's new of you?
Well, I'm just sitting up here thinking, you know?
I got a question for you.
Yeah.
I think girls like, would she like guys do?
What makes you say that?
I don't know.
I'm just...
I'm just thinking.
I don't have to worry about that because Lisa's loyal to me.
No, man, you never know.
You're a girl.
We're very strange these days.
I used to know a girl.
She had a dozen guys.
One of them found out about it, beat her up so bad, she
ended up in the hospital on Guerrero Street.
What a story, Mark.
Yeah, you can say that again.
I'm so happy I have you as my best friend.
And I love Lisa so much.
Yeah, man.
Yeah, you're very lucky.
Well, maybe you should have a girl, Mark.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe you're right.
already i don't know yet well what happened remember betty
that's her name betty yeah yeah we don't see each other
anymore you know she wasn't in good in bed she was beautiful
but we had way too many arguments that's too bad my lisa's
great when i can get it oh man i just can't figure out women
sometimes they're just too smart sometimes they're just
quite stupid other times they're just evil to me like you're
the expert, Mike.
No, definitely not an expert, Johnny.
What's bothering you, Mike?
You're the expert, Mike.
Nothing, man.
Do you have some secret?
Why don't you talk?
Come on, dude.
Is there some secret?
Tell me.
Come on.
Talk to you later.
Mike.
So Park should hire me.
Hey, when Trey Parker gets too old, ring me up.
Call me!
I'm here all night!
Gordon, thank you for the hundred pitties.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't watch the beginning fire again.
I was, hey, Trey Parker!
Right here!
Your next Harry Cartman!
I did not hit her.
It's not true.
It's bullshit.
I did not hit her.
I did not.
oh hi mark i have a problem with lisa she says that hit her
what well did you no it's not true don't even ask what's new
of you well i'm just sitting up here thinking you know i got
a question for you yeah you think yeah what makes you say
that i don't know i don't know i'm just i'm just thinking i
don't have to worry about that because lisa's loyal to me
yeah i'm You never know.
You are very strange these days.
I used to know a girl.
She had a dozen guys.
One of them found out about it.
Beat her up so bad, she ended up in the hospital on Guerrero
Street.
What a story, Mark.
Yeah, you can say that again.
I'm so happy I have you as my best friend.
And I love Lisa so much.
Yeah, man.
Yeah, you're very lucky.
Well, maybe you should have a girl, Mark.
Yeah.
Yeah, maybe you're right.
Maybe I have one already.
I don't know yet.
Well, what happened?
Remember Betty?
That's her name?
Betty?
Yeah.
Yeah, we don't see each other anymore.
You know, she wasn't going to be able to be able to people.
But we have to go to the park right now.
That's too bad.
Melissa's great when I can get it.
Oh, man.
I just can't figure out women.
I know, right?
Sometimes they're just too smart.
Sometimes they're just flat stupid.
Evil.
It seems to me like you're the expert, Mark.
No, definitely not an expert, Johnny.
What's bothering you, Mark?
Nothing, man.
Do you have some secrets?
Forget it.
Why don't you talk?
Come on.
It's just a secret.
No, no.
Forget it.
Talk to you later.
What's going on, Kenny?
I can't.
It was an accident.
I didn't meet a child.
Eric Carman.
I was trying to figure out what voice to do.
I did not hear it.
Did not.
Oh, hi, Kearney.
I think I watched too much so far, guys.
I think I watched too much.
Oh, my God.
How much to voice this?
Scott Tiniman scene?
Is this what I think it is?
Oh, oh, it's the...
I don't know if it...
I don't know.
I don't know if, like, I don't have the clip downloaded,
guys.
Oh, my God.
We'll save it.
I'll save it, guys.
Don't worry.
Oh, like, Kenny Mountain, Charlie.
I didn't see any South Park woods when I was on the website,
but I'm gonna call it here I think I think this is a good
stopping point honestly This was this was a good stopping
point.
I think I think I got a rest now after peak cinema I've been
I've been channeling bangers after bangers after bangers I'm
jealous of the other people playing this game that actually
did voices and I was just What if Dokey Bird was talking to
Dokey Bird?
And also Eric Cartman.
Guys, I found my third voice.
It's a child Dokey Bird and Eric Cartman.
At least I know.
At least I know I have three voices now.
Not just two, but three.
I'm calling.
Guys, whenever Trey Parker gets too old, hit me up, guys.
We'll make so far go off to season 40.
Yeah, 50% increase, guys, in voice acting.
Three whole voices, everybody.
Whoa, slow down.
All right, guys.
I'm going to call it here.
If you are new here.
I usually stream on YouTube so please check me on YouTube
exclamation point Socials I believe and also you want to
know whenever I do my main content over there I have to
stream this game on Twitch only because of Of the I got shot
down by Disney by the mouse when I try to do some dubbing on
YouTube So I'm gonna play it safe now if I do anything that
might have that definitely has copyright material do it on
Twitch So check me on YouTube I do my main stuff there.
If you want to know whenever I stream on Twitch, check me on
Twitter.
I tweet it out whenever I stream my Twitch.
So follow me there.
If you want to support me on other means, I have a lot of
stuff there.
I have like, I have merch, exclamation point merch.
It really helps out a lot to support via merch-wise.
And I have a lot of codes, like Gamersub's code, Fortnite
code, and also EA code.
They're all dokeybird.
And I think that's everything.
Oh yeah, EP merch ends this week.
So make sure to pre-order your EP merch.
Get those tomato boxers before it's too late, before it's
gotten.
I think that's everybody.
I think that's everything.
Thank you so much for the follows, the subs, the bitties,
the primes, all of it.
Thank you so much, guys.
I really appreciate it.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, pause, check, get them
around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
I'll say thank you for the raid everybody thank you for okay
look I'll let you guys listen to my Eric Carmen impression
the people thank you so much Mia for the raid and now while
you guys listen to it I'll I'll fucking find I'm gonna find
someone to raid give you a secret ending it it's just you
listening to me dubbing it the room again I did not hit her
it's not true it's bullshit I did not hit her I did not oh
hi Mark oh hey John what's up I have a problem with Lisa she
says that hit her what well did you no it's not true don't
even ask what's new of you well i'm just sitting up here
thinking you know i got a question for you yeah it was an
unintentional impression by the way it's unintentional i did
not mean to do that i don't know i don't know i'm just i'm
just thinking i don't have to worry about that because
lisa's loyal to me yeah man you never know you are very
strange these days i used to know a girl she had a dozen
guys one of them found out about it beat up so bad she ended
up in the hospital on girl street what a story mark yeah you
can say that again i'm so happy i have you as my best friend
and i love lisa so much yeah man yeah you're very lucky well
maybe you should have a girl mark yeah yeah maybe you're
right Maybe I have one already.
I don't know yet.
Well, what happened?
Remember Betty?
That's her name?
Betty?
Yeah.
Yeah, we don't see each other anymore.
You know, she wasn't good in bed.
She was beautiful, but we had way too many arguments.
I'm afraid stripping.
That's too bad, Melissa.
It's great when I can get it.
Oh, my gosh, stripping's been streaming for 11 hours.
Sometimes they're just too smart.
Sometimes they're just flat stupid.
Other times they're just evil.
it seems to me like you're the expert mark no definitely not
expert johnny what's bothering you mark
nothing man do you have some secret why don't you talk come
on is there some secret no forget it talk to you later
mark guinea why does he i it was unintentional anyway i'm
reading strip um i'm raiding stripping i think he has a
subathon coming soon so i'll give him a little give him a
little love all right guys now we ending for real thank you
for the raid i'm so i'm so sorry about that i ended the
moment luckily i was trying to figure out who would have
raided so he caught me the right time all right